What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity
Welcome to another episode of Challenge Pongfinity
This is a series
Where YOU challenge US
With your craziest ideas related to table tennis
If you idea gets picked, we will feature it and give you a shout out.
So make sure to leave your ideas
In the comments below!
We are going to find out if it's possible to
return Otto's around the net shots
Let's see how many we can return out of 10!
Can I do the magic?
Ooh, you can!
Now I have the right touch!
See! It's 1 out of 1!
Two out of two!
This is going well!
Okay that was a roller...
This challenge is from Anton779
He wants us to reach 200k subscribers
By the end of this year
Since a lot of you guys are not subscribers yet
Remember to do that!
So, Emil got 4.
I'm going to do 5 - at least!
Broken ball - does NOT count!
Aah, that was easy!
With the hand
Muhammed Shaheer wants us to play a rally
While running 5 laps around the table.
Almost!
You gotta run faster!
I will show it's done!
Let the sensei show it's done!
Okay this is not going to work!
Ok, Miikka can continue!
It's looking good!
That's four, one more!
You made it!
Was it tough?
No, it was easy!
Luckily I got it on the first try!
Luckily yeah!
Specle Josh wants us to do 20
shots in 10 seconds
Could be!
That was 10 seconds, yeah!
Thanks for watching guys!
Hope you enjoyed this episode
If you liked it, give it a thumbs up
Subscribe right here
And watch our previous episodes here
Until next time!